all right so he's set and our first
pitch of the ball game akil batu goes
after it and a high fly deep out into
that right field corner back at the wall
and garrow is there to make the catch
one away
boy joey
i'm gonna be ready to go
you know when joey gallows in right
field he's always going to be ready
there was some height to this one so he
had plenty of time to get under it but
he did a really good job of timing his
jump making sure he didn't jump straight
into the wall
got his glove up and over the wall
had some big homers
pretty good arm
maybe not
necessarily didn't didn't have the type
of
career here that one would envision but
a solid player
fly ball out into left field and a nice
sliding grab out there by eli white
and the inning is done
well the speedy eli white once again
showing off his defense ball looked like
it was gonna drop
yelling that he got it sliding in there
nice easy out to end the second inning
is 1-1
that one a brook and bat roller and
throw base hit there's the first rangers
hit of the night
felt like he needed something to change
and he got two hits the next day and how
about this at base hitting his first
time up today
solac got a great start he'll end up at
third back-to-back singles by the eighth
and ninth place hitters for the rangers
the 1-0
tap her back to peralta and they've got
solace in a rundown
haas makes the tag solac is out at the
plate
that's a big out
peralta knew he could not get the double
play
[Applause]
ground ball
to first
a toss to peralta and willie peralta in
the tigers defense
get out of it wheat
texas leaves two
and we're scoreless through three
might waist one here he's gonna come
back in okay he's gonna go away
and cabrera takes it to right for a base
hit
[Applause]
gala was thinking about trying to throw
him in first you see that they did yeah
good ass but not 10 times
here's the 2-2
inside and it hit him
candelario's aboard for the second time
tonight
boy that's a good eyes there it didn't
hit him very hard
kicked me i guess
we might ask if it's a swing
just ticked it and just a piece of the
right elbow
why are you laughing
he's a look at your face
right it's a base hit in front of gallo
tigers will go station to station
because gallo has one of the strongest
arms in all the baseball robbie grossman
comes through with the base hit the
bases are loaded with only one out and
here comes nomar mazara
here it is
ground ball the second could be two
the flip
not in time
and the tigers are on the board
[Applause]
look at those big strides
really not close at first like where he
where he touched that bag it's a perfect
spot right there
just touch it with your toe
willy castro pops up the first pitch
foul territory nate lowe puts it away
but the tigers do score a run
on the fielder's choice and it's one
nothing detroit as we head to the bottom
of the four
outer third
and miggy hit it the other way for a
base hit
look that they are pounding him inside
coming in again
the 1-1 grounded up the middle and
miguel cabrera
is two for three tonight
[Applause]
well i know i would i have to underhand
it
i just put it in the catcher's glove
this is what you get paid to do here's
the one two
and a rope down the left field and into
the corner
white will play it off the wall miguel
cabrera
at third and jamer candelario has a
one-out double here in the sixth
that ball down and in that's the one do
you swing at her don't you
candy knows it's the strike if he
doesn't he's being so rocket down to the
left field corner
payoff to grossman
good walk earned by robbie grossman and
the bases are loaded big spot here one
and two only one away
cabrera's singled candelario doubled
grossman walked
the 1-2 to mazzara
slowly to first bothered by nate lowe
he's not going to get anybody
candelario a late break when the ball
got away and he will score a couple of
runs home for the tigers here on the
miss play by the texas defense
bizarro throws it
and nate lowe makes a mistake and the
tigers take advantage and grab an extra
run by candy coming around he sees them
nobody's covered
see the pitcher standing on the mound
by willy castro they get him at first
and robbie grossman scores
short drives one
left center field that falls deep that
ball is gone
zach short with his second homer of the
season
a two-run blast
[Applause]
talking about it yesterday chef
this is the seventh batter of the inning
tigers get on a roll it becomes
contagious again they make good plays
they pressure
the rangers and all of a sudden here
comes the big clock who's having fun you
can close the book on colby allard
five runs on five hits and five and a
third innings only four of the runs
earned
i don't think very little solace in that
ground ball down to first base low has
it flips to martin covering first and
not in time
badou was just uh
closing the gap on him in a hurry
now the rangers are going to want to
challenge it so let's see
oh my gosh those are
so close but i think martin did get him
i mean
that will get turned over but yeah this
won't take long
there it is
so it is a 3-1 put out
much more polished
three two to short there's a drive
deep left center field
garcia chases it down shy of the track
that's enough to get another run home
grossman scores the sacrifice deep fly
ball
by zach short and it's 7-0 tigers
[Applause]
that is the very definition of defensive
indifference
this ball hit well deep out to left
field near the wall gone
so joey gallo makes sure the rangers
aren't shut out
down to your last out in the ninth
inning down by seven runs
easy for a veteran player like joey
gallo to just kind of cash it in and
look forward to tomorrow i'm hitler so
far in three tries
and he hits his ball pretty well deep
out to right field and that one is gone
that's away and elevated and jonah heim
uses those big long arms to get fully
extended
and drive that ball into the rangers
bullpen
isaiah connor falefa first pitch ground
ball to third
candelario throws him out the tigers get
their first win over the rangers since
july 7th